headline attack of the moose new online
courses are threatening traditional hire
universities we've heard so much hype in
the last few years about MOOCs about a
crisis in education and I want to
provide a little bit of clarity on that
right now so what's really going on
surely with all these high tuition
increases universities must be doing
pretty well right but in fact in Moody's
Investor report of 2013 it reported
thirty-five percent of universities of
higher education reported a net tuition
decrease a revenue generation decrease
because although they've been rising
this ticket price on university
education they've had to actually be
providing more scholarships to get them
to come but we all know that
universities do a lot of research to
right now we receive hundreds of
millions of dollars in research but
actually the last three years federal
government spending on research has
declined at the fastest pace since the
end of the space race since after we
landed on the moon is decreased twenty
percent in the last few years so you
know obviously this is going to impact
some smaller universities but I'm sure
it's not that big of a deal for the
harvest in Sanford's right well
endowment volatility has ever since the
financial crisis has also moved a lot of
universities to reduce their dependence
on the diamonds so a lot of us wonder
well why can't they just suit using
dumbness because if they rely on it too
much and a bad year is screwed up the
cash flows and their operations with
this in mind Stanford Harvard's
president drew Faust said in this 2013
annual report that every revenue stream
upon which institutions of higher
education have traditionally rested is
under pressure and we have to adapt
every revenue stream okay and Bain
Capital released a report called the law
of more talking about that despite the
biggest universities in this field
talking about the pressures that they're
facing a lot of universities are still
building new construction projects
simply because that's the status quo and
it's and it's making their assets very
illiquid and it's putting them into
angel trouble so what can we do I'm not
here to bring bad news I'm here to kind
of provide some encouragement and
optimism because when you look at
history you find that we've been we've
been here before we've been here before
so before we start asking what's this
crisis and what can we do about it we
first have to agree on what is a
university and when we look at what is a
university through the lens the history
recognize that what's kind of depends on
the time period and it's always been
adaptive to the needs of society so you
look at the early 1600s and the
universities that started up on the East
Coast they're focused on civility
prestige and divinity schools and then
the colonies gruen in the 1700s they
focused on scholastic learning for the
sake of learning it wasn't even until
the early 1900s with the onset of the
First World War that the US government
said we need help we need technology
here's some funds and universities built
up their laboratories to provide the
technology that we needed to win that
war and that obviously continued in the
Second World War they build up more
laboratories and after the Second World
War we recognized that we needed to
reintegrate these all these hundreds of
thousands of soldiers back into our
economy and it started to focus on
career trained you know previously
before the end of the world war the
Second World War most of Education have
been divinity schools or learning or
research and now focus on career
training the space race took off in the
mid 1900s it ended in the 1970s so much
more research funding much more building
and guess what at the end of the 1970s
when the space race ended research
funding dropped off precipitously which
is what we're experiencing today and
when universities are building for the
sake of building and then that goes away
many of them went bankrupt so what do
they do they once again adjusted their
business model and said hey well we have
all this research how do we capitalize
on that all of a sudden the office is a
technology licensing focus on how can we
get this technology to market and make
money on that they also focus on how can
we diversify into providing medical
services as another way of revenue
gender
raishin so if you think about it wasn't
till the impetus of the end of the space
race and the reduction that grant
funding that really pushed universities
into action to moving our technology to
market faster so where are we today in
the 21st century when the digital age
we're building building building and
research is funding off is reach
research funding is dropping off tuition
is declining and what can we do so look
we have the smartest minds the smartest
students the smartest faculty a bunch of
great business networks at the GSB and a
lot of resources and we can find new
business models so how can we take how
can we stop this law of more of higher
education of this building and focus on
transforming it to a Moore's law of
providing educational outcomes there's a
lot of things that we can do but I'll
just mention three and three things that
we can do and that we can do together
the first one is to stop excessive
building you know we're hundreds of
years past the era of building
cathedrals for divinity schools and a
lot of the things where they're going
right now or sent you the same but
they're paying lip service to the gods
of innovation in progress you know no
one no one denies that progress is good
and sin is bed you know and so we need
to focus on building adaptive systems of
learning and not on building these
structures to pay lip service innovation
the second thing we need to do again
we're in the era of big data and talking
about MOOCs finally massive open online
classes these classes most people talk
about like they're going to
revolutionize the world provide
education to every corner of the world
but what I actually want to talk about
is not so much the reach but their
richness what I mean is that the real
power and the MOOCs is the fact that
with the analytics it has a
self-improvement engine to so that we
understand what really drives student
engagement and learning for hundreds of
years we've been flying blind higher
education has been teaching students for
hundreds of years without actually
recognizing if they're learning and
finally with MOOCs user engagement
equates to student engagement not only
vertically
professor to student but also
horizontally student to student
collaborative working with machine
learning were able to develop customized
problem sets and curricula for students
so that they can learn their best so we
have an engine here where we can perform
improve the the service that we're
providing for the students drive a
Moore's law of educational improvements
for the students while reducing costs
and this is not a replacement to the
classroom or replacement to the faculty
but rather an aid or service that can
help us use the class or more
effectively for collaborative work and
finally the third point is something I
forgot him right now but i'll bring it
up in one second i hope but uh yes yes
his third point is that with a space
race right it wasn't until the end of
the space race that we figured out we
have to figure out a new business model
for capelin capitalizing on our research
we started the OTL we started focusing
on patents and what we see today is that
we can't affect how much funding is out
there but we can influence where we
decide to integrate on the value chain
of the research so you already see lots
of universities opening up tech
incubators they kind of move from a
licensing technology to actually try to
spin-off companies and Sanford is
actually really pioneering the fact that
last year they start a venture capital
fund called the Stanford bc startex fund
which just in the first quarter of 2014
has invested 13 million dollars in 29
Stanford companies so we're moving from
technology licensing to incubators to
investing so what can we do we're
students where faculty were alumni we
need to get involved in student
governments we need to get a voice heard
from the Board of Trustees you can
participate in different committees for
the Board of Trustees with student
government as alumni we need to vote
with our pocketbooks we shouldn't just
go up money every time the university
comes to us with a new beautiful
business project on a piece of paper we
should be giving money because we feel
indebted to the University and the value
that creates if we don't feel that way
we need to change the system and so I
started with a headline and I'd like to
kind of end with a hypothetical headline
I hope to see from now that recent IPO
earnings from Sanford back company
provide windfall for University Stanford
immediately announces significant
tuition reductions for the years to come
thank you